this is jocko podcast number 335 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening
when the navy's academics had arrived in
1955 to observe udt training their
purpose had been to validate the
course's
individual selection tests the soft sand
runs the ocean swims the harassment of
hell week
and short of invalidating any of those
to develop what they called realistic
selection standards that would reduce
the navy
what the navy admitted was the course's
excessive attrition
subjecting students to a battery of
personality tests and classifying their
individual traits
age education intelligence and so on the
academics hoped not only to predict a
candidate's likelihood of success in
training but also his success in an
actual underwater demolition team
in the course of these assessments they
learned that students below the age of
21 were eight percent more likely to
fail
roughly the same rate as high school
dropouts while students from broken
homes were just as likely to graduate as
anyone else
based on the number of times a student
had voluntarily visited the dispensary
assessors determined that a candidate in
moderate health who quote minimized the
psychological importance of pain fatigue
and intense discomfort stood a much
higher chance of success than quote the
most physically fit who were overly
concerned about their injuries
the least common traits among successful
frog men seem to be
restraint
thoughtfulness sociability
and cautiousness
the most common were responsibility
emotional stability
original thinking
objectivity and most of all
masculinity
later studies had gone on to test a
variety of variables including the
benefits of wheat germ in a student's
diet which proved predictably negligible
and a series of rorschach tests and
psychiatric interviews to determine the
effect of sexuality on a candidate's
success or failure
successful frogman said the sex sex
reports author
appear to require this specific rather
masculine and adventurous occupation
with all its self-destructive and
masochistic implications
because and this was just the author's
speculation of their magical attraction
to the depth of the sea and the security
of the womb
and an unconscious motivation to prove
their masculinity coupled with a fear of
involvement with women
setting aside the psychoanalysts
tendency to project their own
insecurities onto their subject
the navy had not been able to argue with
the udt's results
i have never met a group of more
self-reliant hell for leather characters
wrote reporter bill stapleton after
accompanying a udt to saint thomas and
the virgin islands in 1955
besides their typical reconnaissance
exercises submarine lockouts and tests
with miniable miniature submersibles the
frogmen had also
salvaged a 50-foot yacht from a reef
twisted the tails of passing sharks and
when an american sailor had disappeared
into a harbor on a moonless night had
commandeered a truck roared to the
wharf's edge and as if they had been
scouting the contours of an enemy beach
dove online until they found the drowned
man
in their free time they spearfished
drank untold amounts of beer erected
beachside bonfires and in overflowing
pots of sea water and vinegar boiled
lobsters and astonished the
superstitious natives by broiling
barracuda steaks
eat barracuda barracuda
eat you
they had said
promises reply to frog man nothing but
promises
so exclusive were the udts said one
observer that even rank meant nothing to
them when seen in their standard swim
trunks and knife belts surrounded by
charts and diving equipment and asked by
passer-byes if they were indeed in the
navy
the frogmen would invariably reply
regardless of the asker's rank
nope
we're all in udt
[Applause]
so that right there is an excerpt from
uh incredible book the book is called by
water beneath the waves it's written by
a former seal named ben milligan
and it's it's an outstanding
history of where the seal teams come
from but that little excerpt describing
what a udt man was like back in the day
that assessment is from 1955.
so at that time there were no seal teams
but
but the spirit the soul of the frog man
was there in full form and this is where
the modern day seals come from those
were our roots
those were our forefathers
and it is an honor to have one of those
old-school frog men with us today to
tell us about his experiences in the
underwater demolition teams
what he learned there
and how he applied those lessons
throughout the rest of his life
his name
is lance mann
a udt frog man a water man a surfer an
entrepreneur
a lifeguard
and a damn good example of how to live
life
lance
thank you for joining us
well thank you for giving me the
opportunity to be here appreciate it
that that uh
assessment in 1955 i feel like i know
half those guys that he's talking about
like these are the guys i grew up with
in the teams right
and
pretty interesting that it just
there's something about it that stays
like there's something about that old
frogman that stays
well and i think what the
in the training and the i guess the buzz
if you will and then the subsequent i
don't even know what what all you do to
become a seal of a uh yeah
but uh
they
i i'm always uh struck by how um
how much a part of the old days is is
inculcated into the
modern day trainee and in the buzz
candidate and that
uh and it always kind of catches me off
guard i mean i i love the teams and and
when i i was about
i read something like that about five
years subsequent to that to
when that was written
and uh i think reader's digest had a
deal in 1961 or something like that and
i was a senior in college and i
i was reading that puppy and i said yeah
the you know and i
i didn't really even want to go in the
military but i when i put that down i
said well
if i have to go in the military i'm
going to do that because that sounds
really cool and uh
so it it um
it resonated with me and and it's
interesting to me that
it seems like a big part of the
seal training yeah 100 yeah
and it's it's great i mean as an old guy
that
uh
when i
meet guys and when they they hear these
guys i could do
so much more than i could for crying out
loud and then they're being they're
giving me credit for something that
man i don't know if i had that in me but
by gum i'll take it so
so thank you
well let's let's let's get there uh
let's go all the way back to the
beginning to to where you know to where
you grew up and how you grew up just to
kind of get a feel for where you came
from so
when were you born i was born in
uh in 1939 in in
so
my dad you know he was he was a a
hard-working guy he had just got
finished with graduate school and he was
he was starting his corporate career
and as a consequence uh we moved a
couple of times
but then when the second world war broke
out he he signed up uh with the navy he
was a navigator
uh
in in
i don't i can't i don't know what so you
were born in 39 39 here's your dad a
couple years into his corporate career
maybe a year or two yes and that was
just what guys were doing yeah the war
broke out didn't matter what you were
doing you had a family you got young
kids right you're going you're going or
are you or you were or you had some
occupation where they needed you in it
and so they didn't want you in the
military they wanted you to keep going
with whatever you were doing you have
any idea why he wanted to go in the navy
i don't know why dad did that but uh
because of that we moved everywhere we
lived in hollywood florida we lived in
san francisco and we were all over the
place and we must have moved
and by the time i was about four or five
years old and started going to school i
think i had went to about five
kindergartens
and then
uh about three or four first grades and
then second grade
i went down to one and then third
and then i went to
the same school for third fourth and
a month and a half of fifth grade so i i
moved around a lot and that your dad was
in the navy the whole time is that one
well when
uh he
he got let me see in 1945 i was six so i
was in first grade and that's when the
number of schools that i
matriculated and kind of
tapered down a little bit and so we
settled down but did he get out of the
navy in 45 after the war
yeah he uh
he went and he became an administrative
assistant to a u.s senator from new
jersey that
knew him as a young kid
going to
business school
and so then we kind of settled down in
the dc area for a couple years and then
moved to
up around new york and what were you
what were you into when you were a kid
what were you doing
oh nothing
very worthwhile i i i it was one of
those deals where you lived in a
neighborhood and
uh yeah your baseball team might have 13
guys on it you know and
that's the way it was growing up and
you know like in in new jersey in the
town outside of new york city and then
uh just a bunch of kids getting together
doing doing sports stuff in
porter park i remember in montclair
and so we did that kind of thing nothing
too organized
but then um and what about by the time
you got into high school where'd you go
to high school well i
it's funny uh i went to a school
in montclair in fifth grade
and it was a
and i met some good friends there
and the kids um
uh all my buddies ended up
going to um i think it was montclair
academy for sixth grade up and uh my
parents said well no you're gonna go to
hillside junior high school instead so i
said sheesh
okay uh
so i i did but i i by the time i was in
eighth or ninth grade
it be it it became clear to me why i
didn't go to the private school in sixth
grade that's because my parents are
probably safe enough to send me off to
uh boarding school in new england and so
i i went to high school
at deerfield academy in
in western massachusetts
and so that is that like one of the old
school like all boys schools coat and
tie coat and time yeah no girls
yeah yeah
it was gnarly
[Music]
but uh yeah it was um
it was it's a great school uh
it was
probably a lot better school than i was
a student but i
think thank goodness for uh
for swimming because i joined the swim
team and i i wasn't a grey swimmer but i
was pretty good and uh
and
luckily i had some you know so i felt at
home at deerfield because of swimming
and not not because of the academics too
much i mean i got through them but
it was a struggle and
i don't think i embarrassed my parents
by but i i got through okay
and this is so this is the what late 50s
that's good i i
was there what in the fall of 54 that
graduated in
as a
and then went to college in 1958 did you
have a car
and between
i got a car in 19
well no not until i left deerfield okay
yeah that was it see some of the kids
some of those kids
they graduate and they get a new car
how was that it just seemed like cars
back then
we're so epic oh yeah
and even though cars i think the car
call i mean even today in america we
kind of we definitely focus on cars and
that's usually the biggest purchase
a person makes until they're
maybe 30 and they finally buy a house
but up until then it's like what car are
you getting yeah and back then it seemed
like it was even more so
oh it was unbelievable i remember this
guy joe willard in my class and he he's
really a neat guy and i
i remember uh
when graduation weekend came along and
he was going down albany road and
deerfield which is you know just kind of
a
country town kind of a place and he had
this
50-foot long grave
98 oldsmobile and there was joe man and
it was perfect and he was cruising down
there waving and king of the
world yeah
and where did you end up going to
college
i i ended up going to tulane university
in new orleans and it was a
i don't
you know you gotta you know there's a
say you know when you're religious you
know they're saying you know hey god has
a plan for you and and so all you need
to do is just lighten up and
go along with the program and i
certainly
didn't have that kind of
oh
spiritual
significance inculcated in me at that
point however
you talk about a guy who had no clue
what was going on but somebody must have
because
when i left deerfield i think i was the
only kid in my class that had no college
that was going to take me and so
my parents got me into this great
college in in wisconsin called lawrence
college at the time and they were good
friends with the president of the
college so
he he says yeah okay yeah
a mercy yeah yeah her mercy admission so
i i went there and uh
uh it turned out that
um
we went down for
to to uh to new orleans because my i had
an aunt that lived there we went there
for spring break and i looked around and
said
and they said i said is there there's a
college around here you know and sure
enough there was a tulane university
and
luckily
i had an uncle that was uh tulane at
that time well i think always has always
been known for its medical school and i
had an uncle i was a doctor
and he was pretty prominent around new
orleans and
and so he he got me into tulane you know
as a
transfer student
and when you got down to was new orleans
so this is so now we're talking 15 58 59
maybe
in the fall of 59 because you're well i
mean when you got up to wisconsin
was that just like cold that you just
thought to yourself i got to get out of
wisconsin well
i yeah i i and also my by this time my
parents had moved there and i loved my
parents we were close and everything but
i'd already done time at a boarding
school and so i was away from home so
living with my
parents just wasn't part of the program
anymore you know
and so uh i i thought gee i gotta i
gotta get on my own here so i
i and that really was a big part of
going to tulane and i i was
really stoked with new orleans and uh
the south the first time
that i went to new orleans we were i was
in a seal platoon i was a new guy and we
were flying to
go to hurlburt field in florida
and for some reason
the air crew
had a plan stop from from san diego we
were flying to
orbit field florida and for some reason
we had to stop for a night in new
orleans like for some unknown reason
right
it couldn't have been plano texas yeah
it's a tuesday night
and all the guys are like oh we're going
to bourbon street and i'm thinking it's
tuesday night and of course i'm i'm not
even old enough to drink so i'm kind of
just going along with whatever's going
along
and i thought to myself well tuesday
maybe we'll go get some dinner or what i
just wasn't really expecting much
we got down to bourbon street on a
tuesday night it was complete and utter
mayhem it was chaos there was people
drinking you know girls taking their
freaking clothes off it was why it was
insane
yeah
how does that so so was that kind of the
gig when you showed up there in 1958 was
it similar was it that much of a party
town back then too oh for sure
and
i uh i was pretty straight arrow and uh
i think i had my
well i had my first beer i think in uh
my freshman year up in wisconsin and
there and had i had great friends and
that's in in my fraternity there and so
we drank a little bit of beer but
uh i really it like i honed it to a fine
art by talking about new orleans
yeah new orleans is it's it's
i think it's i you know i've been around
i've moved a lot and i
i about five or six years ago i was
thinking my favorite city in the in the
united states
it has to be new orleans i was only
there for
college uh
and then a
few years later we did some business
down there but yeah there's something
very
very unique about new orleans it's wild
so then my my platoon commander
this was also in my first platoon i
think on our way back or something we
have another weird random stop in new
orleans but he went to tulane oh so he
made inroads and we showed up at like a
party where some kind of fraternity park
i don't even know what it was
but we show up to this this place and
you know it's like a platoon of seals
and all these people all these girls are
there it's just wild yes yeah yeah and i
remember for a long time
for a long time when i was a young
single guy my favorite two cities in
america were new orleans and
lake tahoe
because lake tahoe
was also just wild
yeah and uh yeah so it was like that in
the 50s too huh
oh for sure it uh
and you know we did did all the french
quarter stuff and then
uh
and but the fraternity parties were a
big deal and uh
yeah it was it was pretty wild and crazy
i
uh although
i must say it was probably as much of a
college experience as it was a city
experience but but we would would spend
time downtown in in the quarter and
stuff and
usually you know if you're doing stuff
and then you kind of finish up down the
quarter
somehow you get home
uh what are you studying when you're
going to college i studied uh
uh psychology and then minored in
english
and were you doing with that with any
kind of intent or is that just sort of
like
how it turned out
yo there was a lot of intent okay
because it looked to me like psychology
was probably the easiest subject i could
figure
and then
tangentially i
i started
doing the english thing and i minored in
that
and then i i i became really interested
in school i read a fair amount and
and i remember graduating with a degree
in psychology and minor in english and i
i remember
uh as i
when i started thinking about it i i
really wish i'd majored in english and
then you minored in something else as
psychology wasn't
it it wasn't as uh developed as a
field of study as it as it is today to
so many people it probably was but it
just you just it just didn't reach down
to the rest of the world uh as it seems
to now because my kids have studied it
and boy they're
they're they're learning things that
we didn't weren't even on the map you
know what i was going through but the
english
you know i kind of want to major in
psychology partly to learn about all the
crazy people but
that
when i was reading all these novels and
books
that's where the crazy people were so i
had plenty of that so
uh so english was was good and um
you know i'd say that i'd recommend that
as a major for anybody
so as you're going through college are
you thinking you're going to get a job
as a psychologist are you like what what
are you thinking your future is going to
be because you said you weren't really
that interested in the military at that
when you first oh no no you the only
reason in those days uh if you're a guy
a big part of your life uh from about 16
17 years old on is you got to deal with
the draft because if you don't if you
don't deal if you're not proactive with
the military you're going to get drafted
and you're going to go in the army even
in 1958 yep
yep no kidding yeah
and so i knew i had you know we had uh
rozzy kids in my fraternity you know and
they'd do the rotc deal
and uh so the you know there was a
i mean there was an underlying con
concern or consider yeah the military
was very much a part of your life if
you're a guy and so you're going to have
to either be productive be going to rotc
or
or ocs if you wanted to be an officer or
um
or get married
and marriage was
was a kind of a ticket out of avoiding
the military you know and i think a lot
of guys did that
uh
filled with regret all of them
yeah you know i mean you still think the
military's tough
take how about a wife
[Music]
so yeah you gotta
i thought i always thought that was a
a bad choice not uh not not forever but
when you're in your 17 18 19 20 year old
it's too early to sign up
for that
so you uh so anyhow yeah i i knew i had
to do something about the military and i
i remember talking to some guy who was a
pilot navy pilot and i thought you maybe
i'll be a pilot and then
that
article about udt came up and
and uh remember this guy named king
mallory he was thinking he's gonna go
into udt and we were we were on the swim
team at tulane and also you were like a
legit good swimmer oh
no yeah again like i say
god had a plan we were just starting the
swim team so we we could take anybody so
there there i was
uh
at tulane and we we did form the very
first swim swim team that the tulane had
so we
so i guess you made the team and i mean
yeah well
besides you because in order to travel
you had to drive your own car and i had
a car
so
so we uh
i made the swim team
and what did this what did this reader's
digest article say that really kind of
stood out to you
and i believe i believe correct me if
i'm wrong i believe that admiral
richards talked about the same thing it
wasn't admiral richards i think it was
he also saw a reader's digest article
and said it's it's i mean people might
it's everybody knows about that
if you're in the teams uh
i i'm sure everybody
has is aware of that article whether
they read it or not i don't know but it
yeah it was it was well known everybody
so what did it say in there that that
struck you as well one thing it really
sounded like it wasn't very military you
didn't have to be that organized you
didn't have to shine your shoes you know
you didn't have to do all that stuff
which had
appealed to me tremendously so
uh and i remember one
line in it and it
um
i didn't
it said that
i said something like this that
a
frog man
on the beach
in his swim trunks
with his k bar in his hand
is one of the deadliest weapons
in the military or something like that
and and and that's really dramatic and
very quiet and sinker yeah and
and i i didn't exactly buy that but i
like the spirit of it and i think as you
in the passage that you read that
there is a spirit of uh you know what
i'm i'm i'm in the military i'm part of
a group but i'm my own man i'm i'm
i'm still who i am and i'm independent
and
you're you're loyal to your soul you're
loyal to
uh what you really want to do it just
just so happens you're in this
organization where everybody else feels
the same way and if you don't feel that
way you probably won't get through
training you know
it'll be
so it was
there was something
something rebellious about it here you
are going in the military but yet
you're going in
you're kind of backing into it man they
said i'll go in the military but this is
how i want to do it
and i think i think that was part of the
i think that was part of the psychology
of it that caused causes people at least
it's it's
that's what i like about it there was
like a recruiting poster or recruiting
yeah some kind of poster that i think
they had for
project delta in vietnam and it was
charlie beckwith said something along
the lines of
i promise you
medals
or a body bag or both
volunteer here but i've also seen a
similar thing for udts in world war ii i
haven't been able to figure out the
source of it but it was something along
the lines of
no kp duty no
uniform no standing in line in the chow
hall join the suicide squad udt
yeah like a way to recruit guys man yeah
young young guys read that kind of stuff
and they get all kinds fired up for it
sure
and uh yeah they have to have a they
have to want to take a risk too yeah
yeah
uh so what was the process for actually
joining how did your dad feel about you
going in the youtube he was sold for it
100 percent
yeah yeah my dad was he was a great
cheerleader and uh yeah he
we you know like swimming you know and
he would
he liked to drink a lot too and boy
after uh you know we're at some cocktail
party or something boy you know by the
end of that night i
he had me going to the olympics
it was awesome
but but i i didn't measure up but it was
yeah he he was all for it and did he did
he tell you anything about the udts in
world war ii he didn't no
no and uh even when i joined uh he
didn't
he probably didn't know what the
much about him he was in the pacific and
uh he was in an airplane and
i don't you know and i i don't
i mean the udts certainly were
made a contribution during the war but i
don't know if everybody in the military
was aware of what what all they did
but he was stoked with
me joining it he i think he could see
why
um
why it appealed to me
instead of you know something that is a
little more
organized
and uh
but it um yeah he he was all for it i
felt like he really
was supportive of it and then how did
you get your commission did you go to
ocs were you or were you in rotc the
whole time well it's funny i i i don't
want to digress anything but i i really
didn't know what what to do about the
military up until
uh about the 10th of september
and i had i had a choice of either going
six months in the coast guard
and then three you know like six years
of reserves weekend duty
uh because that was really the easiest
way out you just do coast guard
and then
then you do the reserves
or go up to ocs and i said well if it's
ocs uh
sure that's a tenth of seven i think
they start the 15th and i
so i i was standing on the courthouse
steps there and i just about flipped the
coin as it came up ocs i said well [__]
i better get going here because
i'm driving in my 1957 volkswagen
and so i made it uh so that's how i
ended up going to ocs where was ocs was
it rhode island or was it in newport
yeah and and when you showed up to ocs
is that was that run by marine corps
drill instructors
no other navy guys
oh how i showed uh just it's a good
story because it shows you i didn't know
what the heck i was doing so i pulled in
the parking lot i had my clothes hung in
the
back seat of the uh
of my car
so that the
volkswagen window was my my
blue my preppy blue blazer was up
against the window
and so i closed the car and i thought
well i tell you what i i go i'll go i'll
park here and i'll go and i'll check
into my room then i think i'll go into
town and get a bite to eat
well i go in there
the next time i saw that car was about
six weeks later
and uh i wasn't going anywhere man and
so i welcome to the military i said
sheesh this is
i
now i know why i never wanted to go in
the military you can't do anything
so so i get back out to my car
my first day of liberty
after six weeks
and i was going to put my blue blazer on
however that portion of the navy blue
blazer that was up against the window
had been exposed to the sun for six
weeks and it and navy blue blazers
exposed the sun it turns pink
so i had this half my blazer was pink so
anyhow that's how
that's that was kind of my introduction
when i realized that hey you know what
yeah i'm not in charge of my life
anymore so
welcome to the military did you know you
were going to udt when you went to ocs
was it some kind of contract was it like
pre-designated or did they just tell you
need to
take a test or something when you got
there
no i i had no idea
i i i didn't know it was an option and i
i think
it it was not an option
uh at that point and i think you had to
do a year in the fleet
and then you could sign up for udt
but that was see this was getting in
towards uh
um
62 and i think
whether we knew it or not vietnam was
cooking up pretty good and that's what
kennedy was president
and so the needs for special warfare was
was becoming more paramount at that
point and so during actually it was
during our class uh they opened it up
hey if you want to go directly into udt
from ocs you may
so
i was on that like a [__] on a hot
muffin
i just gotta get there
so did you take a screening test or
something or did you do you had a uh you
had us
uh i think you had hold your breath a
certain length and then there was
another thing that you had to do you had
to go in a was in a chamber and they
pressurized you down to
60 feet or something like that and i
remember that
because
i couldn't get my one of my ears to
clear when i was down there
and uh and it just i ended up bursting
the eardrum but i didn't tell anybody
about it because i knew then
it's on one of those gray hogs out there
where i'd end up so i uh
i i
got through it and they let me in and uh
and boy i was really stoked to
get you know to get to get a chance to
go into udt training was there even any
i'm i'm going to assume there was no udt
people at ocs they must have did they
just look at you like you were a crazy
guy for wanting to go to that yeah i i
was the only guy in i think i was the
only guy in my class
i mean even up until like the 80s
officers that were gonna be seals were
kind of like you were you're capping
your career like oh you'll make captain
but you're never gonna be an admiral you
were just kind of you were you were you
were taking like a sideline you were
taking a side job that didn't really
count to the big navy so i imagined it
in 1962 it must have been just oh yeah
that's a great point you know i rolled
into coronado uh
the high we there was udt12 and udt11
there
and then on the east coast it was 21 and
22 i believe and then
the highest ranking officer
in
on the west coast was a mustang
commander
and his name was mack boynton
and uh he always smoked a pipe so we
called him mack the pipe
and he uh
uh he was and he was the highest ranking
guy in the in the teams
and he was uh i think second
highest-ranking person was a
was a lieutenant lieutenant and then he
ended up becoming a lieutenant commander
and then
uh yeah it was it was bitching i mean it
was just not it was just just like you
you just read about it and uh
and then it just it had it was
you know i was driving and then when i
was driving up coronado i got off the
ferry boat and i was driving up coronado
and the the sun was going down it was
and was the coronado bridge wasn't there
yet not yet so you're driving up the
strand
no you drive uh into town and you catch
a ferry boat in san diego and had you
had you driven your vw across country
yeah what'd you have a vw bug
yeah 57.
what color was it gold
called the gold coast so you drive this
thing across country did you do any
preparation besides like hey you knew
how to swim good did you run or anything
like this yeah they they said running
was a big deal and i remember as i drove
i would check in
to a hot towel joint and then i would
run about two or three miles and then go
to bed and then um
i did that and then when i woke up i ran
a couple miles and go to bed and then
get going
uh yeah i was i i knew you had to be a
fit and so i was working on that
and i had been since i
left you left uh ocs
by the way when i left ocs i was in my
gold coach it was february
and um
snowing and i was driving through i
remember driving through ohio of all
places when john glenn was going around
the world or whatever he did
the epic
space flight that he did and it was i
was just listening to it on the radio
riveted you know it's just fantastic
and uh
so that that's kind of how i got my
start from ocs back to college
was ocs done in six weeks or is that
just when you forgot your first break
well no uh it was done
let me see i started in september
so yeah it was
october november december january it was
about a three or four month program
and uh and so in february i was done i
mean it was i was commissioned and i was
on my way to
coronado making that big navy paycheck
oh
yeah richest guy in the world oh yeah
driving one of the finest cars
modern-day tesla you know
so you certainly you're driving out you
drive out and you eventually get the
coronado yes and you say you take the
ferry from where from downtown san diego
into coronado yeah downtown
what is that a seaport village yeah yeah
it is seaport village now you get off
and you know
you drive into
nab coronado you're looking right
what happens when you check in is
anybody even there well
yeah there was a donald laughlin that
was the officer on duty and then uh this
guy uh i forgot the name of the
other guy that was working with him but
yeah and he was
hey again i i was just also
providential i mean and donald loveland
was this great guy he's very encouraging
and he's hey you know it's he just it's
it's hard and but you're going to do
fine you know and
a lot of a lot of and you know yeah i
could have run into some guys and do oh
man you're going but this guy he was he
ended up being a good friend and
was he so he was he in buds or he was
already in the teams he was already in
the team he was one of the instructors
and he was the officer
uh officer of the day and so he was on
the base when i checked in and he was
cool really cool just like oh you'll be
fine yeah
man that's cool yeah it was really cool
you know and uh
and i i actually as i think back on who
was around in those days and i i think
most of the guys on the teams would
would have been you know
i wish i could say the same i was
talking one of my buddies that's a
master chief now on the teams he's still
in
but he said he was my roommate buds he
said when he checked in he walked in the
room i looked up at him looked up at him
and said quit now and avoid the rush
i was like i'm sorry i was such an
[__]
oh my god that was his welcome award we
were laughing so hard that i said that
to him uh freaking great guy we had so
many good times but that was how i
introduced myself to about you quit now
and avoid the rush
that's really good
good how long did it take from when you
checked into buds to where you actually
got into a class
that was it was about a month uh we had
some kind of course we took they're just
killing time uh and building 401 across
the street on the base
and then udt was in building 208 on
the bay side of the amphib base okay and
then and then the teams were
where the teams were okay so you have
about a month and you're just kind of
training going through whatever kind of
course they're putting through you're
working out
yeah you do you work out on your own
and uh i which was fine i'd just get up
and i'd run
run i'd run quite a bit
swimming i i didn't think was going to
be a problem and uh but the
the running you know i want to make sure
i could keep up on the run so
so i did that uh
you get this and this is still called
udtr right yes
yeah yeah
yeah yeah so it's you it's the
underwater demolition team's replacement
or you need
underwater demolition team training got
it and it's u-d-t-r-a
yeah and so what class were you in 28.
so you're in class 28 was that a big
deal back then did you guys make a big
deal that you were in class 20 it wasn't
like no you didn't weren't even thinking
about it yet i wasn't even thinking
about it i just want to get through the
goddamn thing
[Laughter]
do you guys did you guys wear uh helmet
liners like like we like i did yeah okay
so yeah did you put your number class
number on it
i don't think we did that but we
no i'm sure we didn't
class number wasn't
wasn't a big thing yet yeah not yet yeah
so you do you remember do you remember
when you started you remember your first
day of first phase yeah oh yeah so
they get they heard
there were 14 officers that were going
to start class 28 how many people total
and then there were about another 80
enlisted guys a total in the very
beginning but the first day of training
they do officers
for two weeks the officers had two weeks
of training before the whole class comes
together
and the reason was is that you had to
get rid of the officers that are going
to quit and and actually we probably
started with about 20 something and
we weeded out a number of officers right
away but not too many i mean
so certainly the majority of of the
officers remain in the class
a guy was telling me that um
like before hell week they'll have you
know a class and they'll be
whatever seven officers ten officers
yeah and the instructors will say who
who's number one in charge in the you
know guy racist yeah this is before hell
like they say who's next in charge and
another guy who's next in charge now go
to like six deep
because the assumption is man you're
gonna go through all those officers and
they're gonna be gone bye-bye
[Laughter]
good look at them now man
they're gonna be history so they so so
the officers spent some time two weeks
they're weeding out some of those guys
and
they weeded it down to how many officers
i think there are about eight of us okay
so
what were you guys doing when you were
were they were they treating you like
bud students were they beating you guys
and
tearing you up during those two weeks
before you joined the class
and what were they doing to get rid of
some of these guys well the the runs
were longer
it was all the physical stuff like and
then a lot of cold water but it wasn't
it wasn't
that hard it wasn't bad
the running was pretty
pretty hard and uh i i worked pretty
hard to get ready for it
and i i
as i recall i it
it wasn't a real problem for me but by
gum it was
it was hard and uh
i remember
i think i was in shape for it
but uh there's i remember one there's
one run we had this guy in fact he lives
in coronado today he led the run
and she's
you know he just kept going and going
and
and i remember at the end of the run
i guess i experienced hypothermia which
i'd never known anything about and i
still didn't at that time but i know
that as soon as we got done with the run
and i ran over to the
i guess
some place where they sold baby ruth
candy bars and they eat about two of
those puppies right off the bat
before we went to the chow hall so
and uh the your instructors were these
guys like
korean war vets and world war ii vets
that's a good good question there was
one guy that was a
a world war ii guy and i think
i think he was at normandy
and then there was uh other guys that
were korean
and um
yeah korean war
oh and joe barber yeah he he was the
second world war guy but i don't know he
wasn't a frog man i don't think at that
point
but uh
and then other guys were
were
yeah the couple of the other instructors
post via uh korea and this is 1962 62 on
march of 62.
oh so this is like the seal teams had
just been formed did you hear about that
yeah they and so we went across it when
we got done with training and went
across the street there were 50 seals
uh the seal team one had been formed and
it consisted of 50 guys
so first day of you said you remembered
your first day of actual
training with the whole class
did they
stomp you guys in the ground was it a
more gentle entry would they do to you
well we had a pretty
serious
conditioning hike
um
and so we uh
you know there were trainees strung out
from
the hotel
down down the north you know just
everywhere but uh
but yeah we had a good run
and then we
everybody's pretty hot so we got in the
water it gets cooled off cool you down a
little bit yeah
you trainees look
look a little a little hot and you need
to
get get cooled off here so were people
quitting on the first day yeah
yeah we probably i don't know how many
but yeah we'd lose
the first week there we probably lost
20 guys all together
and it's a guess i don't know do you
think they just didn't know what they
were getting into
i i'm sure that a couple of them just
didn't know that all yeah because i know
the i know nowadays there's so much
uh
a prospective udt guys gonna our seal
team guy is gonna
they're gonna know a lot about the team
yeah and uh but argo you know in those
days
you know there were
there was
yeah they didn't have any idea
and
probably
probably the there's one guy
he was from holland
and he ended up graduating from high
school in
up in the northwest someplace and his
name
he's a he's a good friend of mine
actually lives in coronado now
and his name is dutch uh
swagamockers and uh
and he
when we first stay in the pool
he he could not swim
and uh you know that deal where they
have you have your you have to keep your
hands above water or something like that
i don't know how long it was but it was
you know you need to
keep yourself afloat and this guy
he was a cyclist so he had not one ounce
of fat on him so you put him on the in
the pool couldn't swim
and yeah he was down on the bottom and
he he had his hands up there and he's
also he wasn't real tall he's about five
five six five seven
and he had his hands up there and he you
could tell he just started and then he'd
sink the fingers would go below the
surface of the water
and then he would he would
get himself back up but he made it
through
and then when
he uh
and then all the swimming pool thing and
then finally
thank god
he was issued a pair of fins and then
with his legs as a cyclist
he he could outswim most people anyhow
and so but he
i i'll never forget that guy's such a
courageous guy and how he
able was able to do what he did and with
no swimming background at all that's
insane yeah it really is that's crazy
yeah and he but he did it and he became
he was a very successful
frogman and then he uh
he did some diving after the teams and
yeah but he's he's a
local guy in coronado now and does have
has nice family and good wife and all
that stuff so
so you roll into hell week
what do you remember about hell week i
was it was bitchin haley
i uh
were you was
what was the hype around going into it
was people nervous were people
excited about it were like
were you scared what was the hype going
into it i think nervous and scared
probably was the two
two two biggest feelings about it yeah
everybody was
and that's probably the same today
you know it's just
yeah it was uh
i know in my own head
uh
you know i thought about it a lot uh
i i
i swear there was
there was never a thought of not making
it through hellwig i just wasn't sure
and i think that's how all all of us
felt
yeah we're all going to make it but
we don't know how but
we weren't asked to articulate that we
all we had to do is hang in there
and uh and so
that was my mind said well
what the hell i'll just do it alone i'll
just hang in here and
if you have that mindset then i think it
becomes manageable and
uh
and it was it was hard i mean
you got damn cold and uh you didn't
sleep
and uh
but you knew after monday that there's
tuesday and you know we're just and we
got done on saturday morning and um
and you got through and and it wasn't
you didn't have this feeling that oh god
i made it i can't believe i made it no
you had this feeling well
phew i'm glad that's over with it you
cause i think you i think your mindset
was that you're you're gonna get through
it just
just how the hell you're going to do it
who knows you know so yeah you just do
it how many how many people you think
you lost
i don't know let's say we started with a
grand total of 80 we probably lost at
least half you know maybe
maybe we were down to 30.
i remember we started with like six or
seven boat crews and then at the end we
had four and so you had six man in a
boat and
as i've said before i wasn't much of a
student but i could multiply 60
600 yeah yeah i carry the one yeah
and then you get so was was your
training broken up into phases the way
it is now
so for me i went through first phase
which was like the weeding out phase it
was nine weeks long then we went into
dive phase where you learned how to
scuba dive and drag her and all that and
then went into land warfare i think dive
phase was like seven weeks and then land
warfare was another eight weeks or nine
weeks it was it was somewhat like that
yeah it was definitely faded that first
phase right up to hell week they just
beat the crap out of you you know
and get in shape
and then you had hell week and then i
remember
for a few days after hell week that next
week we we did some we shot guns or
something like that where we because
everybody's pretty sore and so
and then then the dive phase
and then um
uh i guess was dive phase a challenge
no uh for me for you not really no
no it was just were you guys dive in the
old emerson rig where were you guys
diving yeah yeah so you started on open
circuit did you guys do a pool
competency yes oh yeah yeah they we were
well prepared uh i think you know
everybody knew how to do it and we were
we we were a lot in the
we were in the pool a lot and then we
went off
up at point loma a lot if it was pool
comp like when i went through pool comp
was a big
uh hurdle to get over where you had the
twin 80s on you had the double hose
regulated they're going to come down tie
that thing in knots rip your mask off
beat you up down there underwater yeah
it was something that a lot of guys
failed myself included i failed it the
first time i took it um
but
was that like a big hurdle for you guys
or was it more like they were just
instructing you
you know i don't remember it being that
that much harassment uh maybe we got off
easy on that deal because uh there was a
little bit of that but for the most part
it was it was instructive
and i never felt
you know they made you take your regular
you know do things then where you could
hold your breath right it wasn't i don't
remember that being a problem
or a challenge even and then you did you
said you dove the emerson rig
for a closed circuit do you remember oh
i remember we do a closed circuit
thing
but i don't i don't i think i can't
remember the name of it it might have
been him
but it was closed circuit
and yeah i remember some of the old guys
told me they called it the green death
because it was like a horrible rig to
dive for whatever reason i don't know
the reason why they just they just
didn't like this emerson river
i think well i think i think that was it
i remember there was a guy in my this
guy named dowd who died in a training
thing because of the
of the emerson i'm sure i think it was
an emerson
and i remember the poor guy he was in
the
decompression chamber there trying to
bring him back and didn't do it
yeah
uh
the diving you said you were diving off
point loma you're going out doing basic
dives and this kind of thing right uh
and then what kind of land warfare
training did you get
well that's a good question i don't
remember getting much of it at all uh
yeah we didn't do we did a little bit of
marches out at otay where i guess
there are a bunch of houses out there
now but you know
it was a lot of land you know hiking and
going around
but uh there wasn't there wasn't much of
it and and
and it makes sense because seal team
really wasn't part of the mission
anymore yet right uh
so the land stuff we were water guys we
were frog men yeah so we you know we
didn't have to mess with that stuff
so you
well when you wrap up with training did
you go to airborne school
uh i went about a year after training
okay uh some guys did some guys didn't
and i don't know
why my number was delayed but then we
did go to jump school at benning so when
you graduated buds or you graduated udt
training
and then you got stationed on a west
coast team what team did you go to 12.
and what was it like showing up there
what was the what was the deal well it
was great i ran into donald laughlin the
guy i met that very first day i uh
there and they
uh i think first thing we did is uh
this this
fellow officer of mine and i said well i
guess
kind of looked around i said well might
as well go for a run so we we just
started
working out
and
there wasn't a whole hell of a lot going
on yeah this is like what now it's not
is it 1963 yet yeah no
late 62 uh august
we got done in august are you hearing
rumblings about vietnam is that like
not really uh i don't
i don't know if
anybody had been to vietnam yet yeah
i mean even talking i've had guys on
that were you know in the navy in 1965
yeah they still weren't thinking about
vietnam it wasn't the only thing yet and
as late as 1965 then it's kind of kicked
off where everyone that's just about
exactly right because i got out in 65
february 65 and then
um
my brother
uh actually i was driving east to go
work in some
corporate job
and uh
and then he was driving west he just got
done with ocs and he was heading heading
to coronado so you guys high-fived as
you cro christians yeah we met in tucson
drink
we emptied that town of beer
and he went west and i went east and uh
my wife was pissed off because i had
drank too much the night before but then
we we just uh
carried on and he had he had followed in
your footsteps heard about what you were
doing and yeah and thought that sounded
like a good deal yeah
yeah it what what what are you tracking
him as he's going through
training udt training
pretty much he would say i remember him
he got engaged and uh
he got engaged while he was in training
and then got married after
after he was done with training
but uh yeah and he would send pictures
of of his engagement party and stuff and
i mean he had his
haircut like yours and
and so it was uh in yours yeah
so
they um
but you know again you know we don't
have the phone you know it's just
interesting how
how infrequently we would communicate
and yet and always felt up to date right
so when you got to just to rewind a
little bit when you got to udt did you
say you udt12 yes so you get to udt12 do
you get assigned to a platoon do you go
on deployment what do you do when you
get there i got assigned to a platoon
with uh
clay freeman he was a platoon officer
and uh
he was a
great guy went to dartmouth as a big
time skier and uh good good guy but
anyhow so we and then uh we just hung
out and i think we did some
we did a sub op one time off of uh san
clemente and
and then um
oh and then what what did happen is that
we had the
the missile crisis with castro okay deal
or yeah
and that ended up not being anything
really but they everybody loaded up on a
uh
apd i think it's is that what we travel
in and then uh
they just did pt and they got down to
the canal and then turned around and
came back because uh
the crisis was over also like you loaded
up on a ship to go over to cuba for to
do whatever right
right
right and then not having it to do it
then came home would you
would you guys go on deployments you
know like when i got in the teams you
were going to get in a platoon you were
going to do a workup you were going to
go on deployment you're going to get
done with that deployment and the first
couple deploy well actually the first
uh second third
and
fifth deployment i think were all
shipboard for me okay so i was on ships
oh is that right were you guys deploying
like that or
wait when you got put in your platoon
did you say did someone say okay on this
date you're gonna go on deployment
you're gonna go to the south pacific or
you're gonna go to southeast asia on a
ship or anything like that well um
uh
not that organized we would get a sign
and we knew that our platoon was going
to go
at such and such a time you know i think
i think we were due to go out another
six months after we got on
and then um
and you'd go
and i forgot how long the deployments
were but they were
seemed pretty pretty long so did you do
one of those deployments
well
keep talking about god intervening here
uh
what
what happened to me
is um
uh
we we got a new co
took took mack the pipes position
but this new co was a guy who was a
naval academy grad
and uh he was coming to the teams
you know and he said god a naval academy
guy going to run mikhail's navy are you
kidding me
and so bill robinson shows up
and
he took one look at me for some reason
and uh
he said
i don't know how i don't know if you're
going to do very well in the teams i see
okay he says yeah first thing you need a
haircut you know because i was really
taking this
role that they described in this thing
seriously
but being a naval academy grad he
couldn't exactly embrace the same
same thing that i was embracing and so
he says i'll tell you what i'm good
friends with jack suddith and jack south
was the head of the training department
he says i'm going to see if i can get
you a job over there i said
talk about the briar patch yeah i mean
that's a hell of a deal yeah you get me
into the training department now i'm
fine the training department at udt yeah
okay at building 208
and so
this wasn't that this isn't the training
department that ran
uh basic training yes it's like oh it is
yeah
so you're going to be like a udt
instructor udt instructor and how long
you been at the team for
well that was in december i got in in
august so what september october
november i was in three months and this
guy looks at you and says you're
probably gonna be better off as an
instructor yeah i was right
and i was all for it
and uh so i went over in the in the
training training unit and um
and i i just loved it it was a guy i
mean who
being an instructor is a great deal and
uh
you know i was qualified i mean i could
run i could do all that stuff you know
and i knew everything about the what
what trainees go through
but i had no
i i did not deploy i didn't you know i
did we did a couple practice runs but i
but bill felt that it was better for the
overall organization if i was there or
not with him
and uh
so i i was there so i finished up my
my
naval's
career there and then uh how many years
were you instructor for
two and a half years and you put through
how many classes like ten feet well
there was uh thirty thirty one thirty
two three three well thirty class 30 31
33 and start of 34.
because my brother was in class 35
and then um
we uh
yeah and he you know i i was out by the
time danny started my brother
what uh what'd you learn about
humans and and their ability to push
through when you were an instructor as
compared to when you were going through
it yourself
i never was an instructor and so i never
got to see kind of the other side of it
but i've you know obviously got a bunch
of friends that were instructors and it
was interesting some of the takeaways
that they have from watching people go
through these extremely stressful
scenarios
you know that's a good
that's a good point and uh and a good
question
and
there's probably a lot
about that that's that's profound and
and would be instructive and
i
i think i just
uh the way i operated it was probably
just on my gut you know and i'd see guys
come into training and
and you could tell
gee is this this guy's going to make it
or not and it was
it was great watching them and the ones
that are determined and that are really
it's like probably like being a coach
you know like i know my son
played water polo and you know and the
coaches
a good coach is
assesses his his players you know really
well and thoughtfully and i think
i think he could i think probably what
i remember thinking that about
i can't think of any specific case but i
remember
kind of
making a judgment based on what i saw
uh of their performance you know in the
training
so i i i that's about
and i couldn't
i don't guess i had i could
differentiate the ones that could make
it and not i mean between the ones that
could make it not i could differentiate
between them but then you have a group
of
trainees that they got through and
you know other than the common deal that
they were determined and focused and
worked hard and committed it seems
strange
uh that they're really over all these
years they've never been able to figure
out who's gonna make it and who's not
gonna make it it doesn't matter if you
were
a division one wrestler or a division
one water polo player you might quit and
you and you might make it right you
could be a you know person that like
doesn't know how to swim like your buddy
there like gotcha yeah you'd think never
in a million of the years this person
and they can make it yep they've just
not
really figured it out they've really
figured out who's going to make it who's
not going to make it right well you know
it just reminds me there was a guy an
officer in my class
when we were doing the uh the two-week
free officer deal and uh he was a an
olympic swimmer he's a backstroker and
he went to yale
um
god i i hadn't thought about him until
this moment but uh he he was in my class
and i remember this other guy uh in my
class who was a swimmer at dartmouth and
he was a you know he knew all about good
swimmers and he swam against this guy he
says yeah
yeah he's
he was in the olympics you know he said
oh my god yeah and i remember him and he
quit after two days
you know he couldn't run
he could swim
they're going to figure out what you're
weak at aren't they
yeah
yeah it's gonna yeah you have to be
you have to be i was kind of lucky that
i was
i was okay
at kind of everything i wasn't gonna win
anything i never i never wanna i don't
think i ever wanna run my entire time in
the seal teams i don't think i ever want
to impact i can know i never want to
swim but i was kind of like okay
at pretty much everything
and
that is a better way to be than to be an
olympic swimmer or not be able to run
because
betcha
that doesn't it doesn't work i think
this guy's name was dolby i have to look
him up but uh
yeah i remember gosh he was
poor guy he just wasn't built for
running and all the land stuff it was
and if it's a good thing he never had
got to the obstacle course because he
probably would have died but
he was great in the water though
so you spend these two and a half years
uh putting students through
seeing that side of things and then it's
just your time is up in the navy yep and
you decide you're gonna you decide
you're gonna move on i had to go get a
job
and uh you see my heritage a lot of a
lot of the way i was formed
growing up was the the whole boarding
school the corporate deal my dad was a
corporate guy and
and that's naturally what i'm going to
be doing and then
when i got in udt
i realized that's not how i have to live
my life and but i signed up for a
corporate job anyway and i was in this
management training program back in
baltimore maryland
and i love the the company is wonderful
it's mccormick and company they sell
spices and the people
the nicest bunch of people i've met in
any group and uh
and they were they were so great to me
and everything getting started but i
realized
i remember my first day of work i was up
on the sixth floor of this building
and i spent the whole day in there and
as i
it was it was really sunny and bright
when my wife dropped me off at work and
then
at night when i come down to about six
and it was still it was summertime so it
was still light
and i could tell it had rain during the
day and i said
what's this all about it rained
while i was in this building and i
wasn't even aware of it and i said this
is
this is not how i want to live i don't
want to live in a in an office
so then i i stuck with the training
program for a couple of years and then
uh i i had to make a move so i did
but and i ended up
um
a friend of mine was teaching school at
punahou school in ho in hawaii so i uh
i said
so i wrote him i said you got it he any
openings out there so he got me a job as
a
teacher at punahou and i said
boy from baltimore to honolulu that's
not a bad switch
uh
you're tracking your brother
as he goes through
training
and
you know he's he's doing good makes it
through training yep um what is he is he
writing you letters how are you is he
calling you on the phone how are you how
are you tracking like like you said we
don't have uh cell phones in our pockets
back then i think you're right right no
it's much different of course but i
think phone calls uh we would call long
distance and it would always cost a
whole bunch of money to
to call long distance in those days but
it wasn't that onerous and we could we
could we could we could we knew what was
going on
and and as that's happening and now now
he's in the teams now vietnam is sort of
in
you know escalating very rapidly yeah
and is he talking to you about the fact
that he's probably gonna end up
deploying to vietnam no he was planning
on going into the training unit just
like i did uh and
thought thought for sure that that would
happen but then and he did did one
deployment in vietnam
and then came back
and then that was that a udt deployment
yes he was with 12. i know he was with
team 11. so he does a udt deployment to
vietnam
and they're doing
the kind of udt stuff yeah working a
little bit but it wasn't really
well i shouldn't say that because i've
talked to a bunch of ud t guys that did
some really dangerous stuff in in
vietnam um oh there was they were doing
ambushes and stuff they're playing with
guns and stuff yeah it was
it was it was different
and and he came home and what was his
what were his thoughts about that
deployment what do you tell you about
that uh
well he
he he just thought that
he he wasn't sure how
how much he and
how purposeful it seemed to him i mean
he wasn't rebellious he was going along
with the program and happy to be a part
of the team and
and all of that but it wasn't
he was just it was just something he had
to do he glad he did it and got it done
but then
uh the whole the whole vietnam
spirit is pretty pretty grim even with
the teams even with great people like
udt guys and
it's just
no one really knew what they were doing
and
they'll tell you gosh we were over there
and we didn't we weren't really sure
what was going on
and then um
he did tell me like this one instance
they were setting up they had an ambush
all set up and then
some vc come down and on in the river
and they uh
and danny
danny said that he had his gun up ready
and he was ready to let it rip
and then he felt this tap on his
shoulder and there was this enlisted uh
doc
i forgot his last name but he was a
medic guy and um
and he said
he shook him off and so
danny
kind of lowered his weapon and uh
and then next thing you know there's a
whole boatload of them coming down and
it
somehow the doc was aware danny wasn't
but the doc
said hey
we don't we don't want to play guns here
just now we're outnumbered and sure
enough um
they got through but there was a
it was that kind of thing that was going
on in vietnam no one ever really
knew what was what was happening
and
he
so he gets back
and then he was hoping that his next
deal would be to
get get assigned to
the training unit
and um
but instead he got he got assigned to
seal team one
and uh they were heading out they were
going to deploy to vietnam you know
shortly
and i remember his friend of ours lou
he was a officer in the teams and
because danny was married and
lou said hey
and danny was pissed because he wanted
to go to the training unit you know and
so
um
but he's fine with it he's that's what
i'm gonna do and so luce said hey you
know a single guy and he said you know
let me take your place i'll take your
place and i'll i'll go in the teams and
you can go to the training unit
because lou was in the training unit
already and uh
danny said no it's uh
i'm going to see this through you know
so he did
and
and so
it's just kind of the thing it works out
but
and then so so he goes on to deployment
in vietnam did you hear from him while
he was over there
not from him
he was over there for about a week and i
got a phone call from
uh his
uh from the ceo of seal team one who was
frank uh anderson
and he said that
he said that uh
danny was killed
and i uh
so that's
the last i heard
the first and last i heard of that
deployment
and
i was in baltimore at the time
did that
uh make the cubicle you were sitting in
all day seem even smaller
well
i had pretty much committed to
moving out of that cubicle anyhow so
that in in and of itself wasn't
wasn't a problem
but it did did raise the
you know
of course my parents uh
were devastated and stuff as
as were the parents of 50 000 other
people and
uh
but it did
and then uh that was in april and so in
august i would i would be coming back
out for the uh
we all you had to go two weeks of uh
training um because of the
so they were still in the reserves i was
still in the reserve so i i was destined
to come back to coronado and do that
in august and uh
so
um
but i knew
i knew then i probably would
figure out a way to do something else i
actually during that two-week deal i
found out about punahou and
and i already made a plan to get out of
the cubicle but
um
but going to uh
but it did raise the question
of uh
should i go back in and because frank
has he said he says he didn't ask me to
come back in but he said that uh
i i brought it i kind of mentioned it
too and he says well boy if you want to
come back i'd love to have you you know
because we got along well
and actually bill robinson the guy that
sent me to the trainee and we ended up
becoming real close friends but
um
but uh but frank says well yeah yeah
yeah if you we could use we need we need
people and we'd love to have you back
i said well i'll think about it and um
it was a i was wrestling with that for
a few months and then
we got done with one of those
uh during those two weeks we got a lot
of briefings from guys that were in
vietnam
and they would uh tell us what was going
on
and uh usually we were
and so we'd get we'd listen to those and
and i remember
we were out uh
in a break during those briefings and i
was we were out kind of smoking
cigarettes and just kind of hanging out
and taking a break and
and tom jerusi who had just got back
from vietnam
uh
and i were talking he he he i put him
through training and we were good
friends and
so i
i mentioned during the deal that
i was thinking of going back in
and uh
and he looked at me and he says
he shook his head he says
it's all [__] the vietnam's all
[__] he says you
you don't want to go back in
and uh
and
for some reason
or i think
i think he was right about vietnam i
mean i think everybody realizes that
that was that was a mistake it was a
horrible mistake and
a lot of a lot of people it it cost the
country a lot and um
and it costs a lot of families a lot
so i i
i
my personal decision was you know i
probably another month i decided that no
it's
it's not the right thing to do i
i
[Music]
i i guess i thought of my
parents i thought it i i just i just
thought about the whole vietnam thing i
guess and
and
i'm not sure exactly what caused me to
come to that
come to that decision
but
it it just uh
it just doesn't seem to be the right
thing to do yeah i can't even imagine
trying to you know you trying to tell
your parents that you were going to make
that decision that doesn't seem like
that would have uh
been
been the right thing to do in that
scenario
hey who knows you know i uh i didn't
it never really got that far so i didn't
have to
really hurt my head over
uh but i it's a decision i made
did you stay in the reserves though yes
uh well you you were obligated to um so
i stayed in for about seven more years
and then
then got out but it was
i was more into
living in hawaii and teaching school and
and
getting getting get go and kids were
showing up
showing that yeah when did you start
surfing
i was a ripe old age of 22 in coronado
when i first got to coronado and uh
they uh
you know like i said when i first pulled
in there and those cars with the boards
hanging out and everything were
kind of just so compelling so i signed
up
and
i bought a board bought a hobie
uh phil edwards bottle in uh dana point
and drove up there and got it and
started surfing was that before dana
point was they put all the yeah oh man
was it was it as good as like malibu how
good was it
it it
usually was bigger yeah it was as good
as malibu and it was this huge and it
was usually a big swell uh
north swell and then
it was yeah it was it was killer dana so
that must have hurt uh being in
baltimore as well now you can't surf
yeah although i did go to rehoboth okay
yeah yeah we did went there a couple of
times
and uh
yeah but i i really had to get back to
california really important
and then you end up in hawaii you're
teaching school
and are and and you're just getting more
and more or i should say i guess
continuing to find other ways to be
involved in the water at this time yes
and then uh
it was
i got really interested in outward canoe
racing and um
and so i joined this canoe club and
there was one other guy there that was a
hawley guy and the rest were
uh lochoyin and uh we got on a crew and
uh i loved it and became real good
friends with the coach as uh baby belle
and he uh
he he was great how how long are those
races
well the uh you have the regattas and so
if you're like i was senior man and
those are about a mile and you have
buoys you go round and round
and then then you have the distance
races after the regatta season is over
and then you have the distance races you
know there's one that runs from
kailua to
waikiki 20-something and then
the granddaddy of all the canoe races
the molokai race which goes from holly
alone harbor and on on molokai to uh
waikiki
and so uh
and how big this is uh how many people
are in the canoe six
and then like when you do those long
distance races you have nine nine people
in the canoe
and uh
you
three are resting and then you just
change and you make water changes as you
go
and you change every 20 minutes or so
and it's about a six hour race
so it's it's you're it's you you have to
be in pretty good shape but it's
[Music]
but you do you know you're just getting
that how'd you do in all those races
well the first year we uh
let me see i guess our first year we
were really bummed yeah we we got beat
by waikiki surf and outrigger we were
third
and then the next year
we
we won it
and then the next year after that
we won it and then
and then my last year um
i was up on the mainland starting to
work for chart house but they
they said i could come back and paddle
with them in the molokai race so i went
back and we
we did pretty well but we didn't win
but it was it was a good race
and is that what your transition was out
of teaching school going to work at the
chart house
it was yeah i was teaching i was working
on i was waiting on tables in waikiki
while i was teaching school i worked at
chuck's steakhouse
it was at the outrigger hotel
and buzz's steak and lobster who's down
on beach
beach walk
and um
yeah i i i knew
i i knew i wanted to go to work for
for the chart house because there were a
couple of udt guys that were
actually there's one udt guy and then
joey cabell who's a big time surfer that
started the very first chart house
in aspen
and his name is buzzy ben and then buzzy
and ron smith were classmates in
udt class 16.
is 16 or 19 but it was before me and i
became friends with ron
who's a dynamic character and just a
great personality and
he was at this point in the late 60s he
was um
president of chart house and then buzzy
was kind of retired and
[Music]
joan was
ron was running the company and that's i
so i wrote him a letter i said hey i'm
working at a steakhouse in waikiki you
got any openings and he said sure yeah
come on so i ended up working for the
chart house and what what did you do at
the chart house there was a chart house
in coronado when i was when i was in
buds and when i got the seal team one
and
man i used to go to that chart house i
don't know like
once a week maybe once every other week
and get prime rib
and it was weird because when i grew up
we didn't eat a lot of steak when i was
growing up so i didn't even start liking
steak
and
and prime rib until i was like uh in the
navy because then i could buy it myself
yeah but we used to go i used to go to
charthouse with my buddies and but we
and i knew like there was some i had
some knowledge that this was some kind
of team guys that owned this thing but i
never made any connections with every
anybody never like
never talked to anybody no one ever said
anything about it
but so were you involved in that chart
house in the early 90s in in coronado
well even before that i started in 71.
oh damn the chart house has been around
since the seven years i think they did
the
oh yeah the first one in aspen was uh uh
1960 i think 96 it opened on july aware
of that july 4th
and then the second one was in newport
and that was i remember i was in the
navy when we ate it at the newport one
and then uh
that was the second one and the third
one was uh
at
shelter island okay yeah on yeah shelter
island okay and that's when ron
joined the company
and um
yeah he got out of the navy about 64 65
and then went to work
because of buzzy he and buzzy were tight
and this is someone you said named buzzy
bent yeah not buzzy trent the right
surface guy yeah no no it's buzzy ben
it was a great surfer himself and so you
were working as a waiter
in hawaii right and you write these guys
a letter they're all team guys you're an
old team guy yeah and they're like yeah
we'll hire you yeah did you tell me
you're a waiter did you tell him you had
some big management position
no no i told him i was a waiter i was
just and uh
and
i knew i knew ron fairly well at this
point personally you know and so he
he he believed me you know that i that
and so i we had kind of a training
program this was in 71 when i came
i came back i came back from honolulu to
to redondo beach
and um
did a training program there for a few
months and then
then they
ron and actually john creed the other
guy who's the executive vice president
he was a old surf guy and and water guy
and they said they were talking about
gee we'd like to get a
a restaurant a chart house in hawaii
because and there was one there but it
wasn't part of the corporate chart house
on the mainland so
i said well gosh you ought to you ought
to buy
a restaurant from jerry mcdonald he has
them on maui and so
we ended up so
that we ended up buying the sugar cane
in which is in lahaina
and then made a chart house out of that
and that was my first real assignment
with chart houses to go open that build
it get it ready for business and that
was my first kind of real assignment
what year was that
that was in 1972
is when we
because danny was born in november of 72
we went over in december of 72 and
bought the chart house and
and then we
stayed there i actually i
i have to
i gotta acknowledge
the heroic wife i had at that point she
gave birth to danny on november 11th
1972 and
uh december
10th or 11th we were
on maui uh
she she was a month-old child months
after giving birth and we were opening a
restaurant
and she
she
courageously charged through it and did
great probably no one else could
do that
and uh how so how long how long were you
running that chart house i ran ran that
baby for about a year
and then um
i came
back
to the
let me see i had oh yeah and i came back
to um
the mainland oh yeah yeah that's right
we i ran that for about a year and then
uh about that time chart house was
getting bought by another
uh by another corporation it was a big
it was the largest franchisee a burger
king restaurant so they they wanted to
diversify and so they bought the chart
house at that point consisted of about
seven or eight restaurants
and um
at that point
so they asked me to come back for that
to be a kind of a regional manager guy
in california so we we moved back
and uh
i again it was almost the same sort of
experience i had in baltimore i said
it's getting pretty corporate guys and
so uh how about
can i go back to maui and uh so i went
back to maui and stayed there for
quite a while still with the chart house
and it's still with the chart out yeah i
went back there and then we
i ran
the chart house that had opened a year
earlier as a manager i saw
and then we started
developing restaurants in the islands
and uh
and
then i became kind of a regional guy out
there then and how long did you stick it
out in in that business i stuck that out
uh
[Music]
i was there
let me see so 70
because the restaurant business is
really hard
well it
it it is
although as many of us from chart house
like to say that yeah i wouldn't work
for a restaurant company unless it was a
chart house i mean chart house was
pretty well you you just described it
it's a
special place and it was and uh and so
in fact today
even though the chart house is no longer
in existence um
there's a kind of a
facebook group
that has uh
the um
it's the old old chart house employees
friends and so on and they're boy
they're just
it's a it's a great group they're very
dedicated to the charity house and they
say you remember this when this happened
and somebody fell in their face in the
avocado dip and yeah
it's just so there's a lot of history
there that gets retold
in facebook forms
but well how long did you stick with it
then
and then well i stuck with it
uh
until about 76 and then i built a my own
restaurant up in makawao and uh
i just made it i just ripped the chart
house off we had a salad bar
you know and we had our
deal and and but it it took off it was a
great restaurant very very busy
and um
and so we ran that for a while we were
living in lahaina and it was about a
45-minute drive up to makawao and it was
i wasn't i was kind of getting tired of
that so
i asked the chart house guys if they
wanted to sell any chart houses so i
ended up buying another chart house
right outside of boston in duxbury
massachusetts
and again my courageous wife who was
pregnant with
our youngest child uh
and
we loaded up and went there ran that
restaurant for about a year
and then
um
our our
little baby dougie was born there and
then we uh
um
and then chart house
they they ended up buying that
restaurant back from me
and then offered me a job back with the
company in california because they were
going to do a leverage buyout from
pillsbury by this time pillsbury owned
the owned the chart house and
and they were going to do a leveraged
buyout so that he asked me to come on
back and help help with that so where'd
you go where'd you move back to coronado
back to coronado and what year was that
and
you now you're now you're still working
with chart house yeah are you having to
go to the restaurants every day i mean
what are you doing well i was a regional
manager guy and then um
oh i was in their training department
for a while and then i was a regional
manager guy and i my region
i was living in coronado
my region was in hawaii
and colorado
and so i had three fairly
nice places i was going to say rough
rough tours
hey how long did you stick with that for
that up until the
uh time sam zell bought the chart house
which was in
98. or something like that
and sam sell he's a huge real estate guy
i think is he the biggest real estate
owner in the world or something
something like that yeah i mean it was i
was talking with an accountant that knew
him
in chicago
and she said that
the saying in chicago is that if sam
jumps out of a 20-story building you
ought to jump after him because he's
probably going to make money on the way
down
so
uh
the um
yeah and so i did i stuck with that
until 1998
and then um
i moved back to
coronado uh
and then we uh
oh and then
danny my other boy said that why don't
you come and watch me like her and i
said jeez really okay so so was he a
lifeguard at this time yeah he was at
north island we were and how old are you
at this point
i was uh
i was about to turn
was it
50 or 60. he was about to turn turn to
60. and he's telling you you should
become a lifeguard yeah and so we i went
to really start training so this whole
time are you just in the water still
and you're still working out are you
still training like how are you staying
in you thinking about going to lifeguard
academy at age 55 or 60 or 50.
even 40 whatever whatever it was i'm not
sure
i think i went through in
99 so he said that's 16. is that 60 yeah
yeah so you're 60 years old going
through the lifeguard academy well i
think i was a couple years younger i was
in my late 50s so okay
and
how are you staying in shape all this
time oh i worked out so you work out
every day religiously i i even now as a
guy i'm about as decrepit as you can get
but i i do something
and
it's an embarrassment you know people
laugh at me as i go down the beach and
everything but that's tough
now how about what you're eating when
you're working at all these restaurants
you got free access to like all kinds of
food all day and night how are you not
just powered into you know those that
freaking hot brown bread that they used
to have at the house are you not
freaking putting on like 80 pounds of
excess fat from that well i think that's
really my motive for working out is that
hey if you work out hard enough you can
eat anything you want
and i say in order to keep my eating
lifestyle
functioning and flourishing then i work
out and but lately you know i've got
these children that are nazis about food
i can't eat this i can't eat that i mean
so
i'm a little more disciplined
so you're how how many hours a day would
you say you worked out like when you
were let's just say you're 40 years old
you're working at the chart house how
many hours a day are you working out are
you going for a for an hour run two hour
run you're doing pt on the beach what
are you doing
well we got into cycling too okay and uh
cyclists yeah they're really crazy and
so i got a little bit of
fringe craziness out of that and we
would
we would ride
well like my daughter and i did a we've
got a tandem bike and we rode from aspen
colorado to taos new mexico which is
about two 250 miles and then
and then we rode from there to
well we drove down to albuquerque and
then we rode from albuquerque back to
san diego and she she was right there
with me and uh
we did it i don't know hundred and some
a day something like that for but uh
those were that's more
long i i think
i think the
probably the
probably the most important thing for me
is is the consistency of working out and
i have a friend um
he he says
motion is lotion and guy you know that
really if you keep moving you're going
to be all right you know and
and it's like this morning i hadn't been
in in the water for a few weeks and uh
when i went to bed last night i said
you're you're in coronado the first
thing you're new to tomorrow is you get
on your paddleboard and you go for a
paddle
and paddling is important for me because
like i said i'm
i'm pretty decrepit and kind of a
physical disgrace but
i i can still paddle i hope and we're
going to find out tomorrow morning so
that i did go for a paddle this morning
for about
half an hour 45 minutes
and then i intend to
lengthen that out but i spent some time
in taos and the problem there is that
the paddling isn't i mean it can be done
but you have to go down to the rio
grande river which is which i'm happy to
do but i in the
winter it's a little nippy you know so
um but when i go back i'll probably go
back next week and but i'm going to get
get to paddling because i got in the
boy my first couple strokes off
on my board this morning it was like the
tin man and the boss man you couldn't
jeez
you know
you could hear the sirens going on
people call 911 this geezer yeah this
geezer he just pulled away from the dock
and i don't think you don't make it
but you know what
the miracle of paddling is by gum after
about 15 or 20 minutes
the pains that i was feeling those first
couple strokes
i didn't feel them anymore and you know
and like okay i'm gonna pick it up here
a little bit and
gee by the end of it i just felt like i
felt fine you know so that's the stuff
that i have it's a solution i guess
exactly
so how so you you end up going through
the lifeguard academy yep and you you
actually become a lifeguard oh yeah it
becomes your job you know what i i
realized uh
i was kind of i had about 10 years in
with the north island
and then
i got fired because this lady took over
the all the lifeguards and she found out
that we were drinking beer in the tower
at three and i i wasn't with them but
some of these young fellows were a
little
less disciplined
and got busted and so i
i was part of that great um
and got uh so anyhow i ended up so you
got fired as a lifeguard now you're what
you were like 60 years old 60 something
years old
for being a miscreant drinking beer on
the job i was getting the i was getting
in the in my 60s i and i wasn't i wasn't
even part of the farm i just fired
everybody well she fired that group
and then i
was up it was in new mexico or something
and i came back and i wanted my job back
and she just wouldn't give it back to me
so i i guess i didn't actually get fired
but i sure didn't get rehired
so then coronado uh i don't know if
sean carey who's the captain down there
the one a wonderful human being and he
said
he says
uh
he said well i you know he well dougie
and i tried out that same that same t
yeah we both would decide yeah
so you wait as
youngest son try out for the lifeguards
at the same time or
were we uh was that the summer before
you got married
um
yeah i think it was i think it was well
he and i go down oh yeah that was it and
there were eight of us that were
that were going to be
applying to be a lifeguard shop and so
this guy the the guy that was running
the
the pt stuff that we had to do in order
to qualify
uh
he he had us all up and and the first
thing was a swim i think out to the buoy
and back and then we had to run up the
beach to the other end of the beach you
know 150 yards or something like that
and then there were a couple other
little deals like that
and uh
i remember
there were eight of us and half of them
were girls
and uh dougie was first on all the
events and i was last on all of the
vents and i remember after that first
one you swim out and go running up the
beach and i got
and there was dougie was at the finish
line already he was toweled off i think
he was having a sandwich by the time i
got there and
so i finally got there
and i
and then this guy was timing it and i i
i i was kind of bent over hold up
holding myself up on propping myself up
on the knees and
i kind of saw my mouth to dougie i said
how did did i make it you know he says
yeah no you're good you're good you know
so i guess i got there just in time but
i so then i they hired me
and then the second year and i you know
i was hired with the city
and then
uh
and then the next year you know i was
off for the
winter time because they they let
everybody go but the next that summer i
was invited back
and i went down to the tower and i said
god do we have that that pt stuff and i
said i gotta start training for that and
and the sergeant there at the time says
no you've already been on you don't have
to do that
those
events anymore
it's like sort of like i say you know
god god has had a hand and sparing me
through a lot of stuff that i didn't
have to so you know so anyway so i
stayed on for about 10 years
and then uh
uh yeah about a year and a half ago
two years i guess i've missed a couple
of summers and it's it's a heartbreak i
i i drive by there and wistfully look
out at
at the tower i used to work in and
and i wish i had my old job back but it
is a hearing deal
some doctor just jabbed me on the um
the hearing uh he said i couldn't hear
certain
voices because they were a certain range
and so so anyhow i got
i couldn't qualify as a lifeguard
anymore and i
you know i argued that well i'm not sure
that
that the hearing is that big a part of
lifeguarding but anyhow i find so you
know i walked away begrudgingly
now it seems like along the way i've
talked to uh some of the i guess it's
the next generation maybe a seals a
little bit younger than me maybe 10
years behind me
and i guess it's when you were in
coronado that you you developed a bunch
of relationships and mentored a bunch of
these the next generation guys coming up
they all love you
well they were wonderful guys i mean
it's i love you all come about well
lifeguarding uh there was uh
sam was at the beach um
uh pepper's at the beach
um
there were there were others oh and then
charlie who was you know uh charlie
keating who
uh wow
he
he i've i've known him because he was a
sony and he would come over
and uh he's just this wonderful kid
uh and he started coming when he was
like 13 14 years old and then so you
remember him
chuck eating when he was 13 14 years old
yeah because he was a coronado for the
summer right he would stay at my house
oh okay
how did you how did you how'd that
happen i mean well oh well
um
his cousin bobby
and
and mikey were
uh their names were black but they're
keating family kids
and charlie was one of their cousins one
of their 800 cousins you know and
catholics you know so
uh
they uh
but so that's how i got acquainted with
charlie and uh became a dear friend and
wonderful guy you know just just a great
guy and and so in the summers i mean
it's it sounds from talking to some of
his friends that you were kind of the
reason he decided to go in the teams
um
i i'm not aware of that i i necessarily
i knew
i oh well his dad did call me and said
hey lance charlie's talking about going
in the teams do you
i said can you help i said well i'll do
anything i can i so i looked at i think
i found a name or something i didn't do
much of anything really except
referred him to somebody who who really
could help him
and so that's how he got in the teams
and then but i'm real close with that
whole family
and uh
and charlie
uh who was killed dad's name his name is
charlie also
and he knew about my brother danny
and uh
so there's
and then charlie's brother billy
is also in the teams or was in the teens
i think he's getting out
um knew about
my my brother and so there's a there's a
kinship there that we we feel as family
and um
we
you know we we stay in touch and on may
i think it's may 3rd is that
when charlie was killed
in 2016 was that 2016 he was killed
and so anyhow charlie and i you know
when i go to rosecrans i'll take a
picture and send it to him and and
that's one thing good about these damn
iphones you know you can communicate
boom when you want to you know yeah and
um
yeah he's definitely a a special guy i
mean uh
i when
he was coming up in the teams you know i
was in a position where i was teaching
land warfare and stuff like that so you
know and so i i would see faces you know
i'd see guys yeah but unless someone was
either really good or really bad i
probably wouldn't remember me you know
he was you know one of the guys like i i
remember this guy and um but man like
some of the like the stories you hear
about
about chuck is just like he was just a
freaking epic guy um yeah and he's one
of those guys you know you look at all
these pictures of him that you just you
just know that this guy was just
such an awesome
guy to have in your platoon
and he left such a mark on so many of
the team guy buddies of his and yeah uh
got a great thing going now they got the
the c4 ranch up here in san diego which
is a beautiful place a bunch of awesome
people and it gives gives guys a place
to be able to go and
unwind and take their families and spend
time in nature and all that kind of
stuff so the his his name is is living
on and he's still helping the
his brother seals through that thing
that he's doing yeah i yeah no for sure
it's a great legacy
and um very worthwhile and and
i know his dad's involved and then uh
brooke his wife i think is really
involved and so yeah it's it's it's
important it's significant and
that you know they found a great piece
of
property up there and i think i think it
serves a
it's filling out the mission in a great
way yeah yeah
uh so you retired i guess from the
lifeguarding thing that's what happened
and so and so what are you up to now
uh you know that's kind of a problem
uh
drinking beer with the drinking beer
with the youngsters
and i i
i i lately
uh
i spend more time feeling sorry for
myself than i should you know and
and then dougie and i were talking and
um
we uh
actually i'm
i got i'm involved with with dougie um
my son who and then this guy sam uh
blair down in louisiana
uh who was in the teams and then moved
to louisiana and they
they started talking about uh developing
um
a coffee company
and uh
and dougie and i were just chatting
about it and uh
and i started thinking god
it's just another
wonderful thing that's
coming to me that i can participate in
and so
has asked me to
well we we just chatted we just
naturally assumed that i would have a
a small role and nothing too responsible
or that requires any talent or anything
but something that i could be involved
myself with and uh
i mean it was
uh
the god thing again you know maybe maybe
this is a blessing of sorts so
we've just been fiddling around with it
for a few weeks but um
we we want to start this coffee company
and because we're pretty sure we've got
a a great source there's a guy down in
louisiana
who was the sole
importer of this
of this coffee and it's grown in
honduras and the only only importer in
the u.s is importing this coffee
and it's coming from louisiana which i
love you know it's across the lake from
new orleans i mean going you know and so
uh it's all sort of coming together and
um
and so at 82
soon to be 83 you know were there were
times
because like my my roommate from tulane
who was 83 a great deal older than me he
was 83
and he's told me he says hey man you
know you don't want to be 83 it's really
rough you know
so i said oh shucks hey yeah okay okay
so
um
anyhow he's he
uh he's just telling me that
it's not good so there are a couple uh
ever since i got couldn't make couldn't
pass a hearing taste test because i'm so
goddamn old you know
so i can't pass a hearing test so i can
no longer do what i love to do
and be with the people i love to be and
you know i'd wake up in the morning
and i i remember one morning i woke up
and i looked
on you know just kind of looking over
the side of my bed and i could see
i could see some dust balls under this
table near my bed and i said
you know
that's probably about the most important
thing you got on your list to do today
is clean those goddamn
puffballs up and i said hey man life's
got to be better than this we got to do
something
and so
when we started talking about developing
a coffee company um
i i'm really excited about it you know
and i'm with
i
probably one of those creative guys i
know my fourth child
and uh he's artistic and comes up with
great ideas and he's entrepreneurial in
spirit and
uh
yeah hell
yeah we're gonna make a coffee company
by golly and uh so
it's obviously we're just starting it we
think it's gonna be great well we know
it's gonna be great but uh and you know
i'm that's what i'm doing now i'm a
coffee guy now i'm kind of the
colonel sanders of
coffee yeah
i'm pretty excited for the coffee
company going to be called big yellow
coffee big yellow what's that all about
well you you weren't aware of it when
you when you came up to us as a we were
out in the parking lot but my van oh the
van there's a big yellow big yellow and
uh i've had that puppy since dougie was
a junior in high school
and so
um it uh
so that
we've got and you know because like i
said the guy's artistic as hell he
designed the coffee bag for it and
everything and
uh
it's the big yellow coffee company and
if you don't think the coffee isn't
going to go flying off the shelf man
you
haven't lived it's going to be great i i
really from what i know
about coffee i i expect to
know a lot more from now on you know but
uh i the the the the components sound
good i mean this guy's the sole
importer of coffee of this particular
coffee from uh honduras and the thing
that's really significant about this
coffee guy is that he's the only one
that we're gonna buy coffee from
and we're uh
we don't we're not going to be like you
know he's a soul uh
distributor just kind of a soul grower
right yeah he's a guy in honduras
yeah yeah it's going to be a single
single origin
um
source do we have do we have a website
yet
it's in in the work it's in the works
oh no
what's the website big yellow coffee.com
and if uh if you can't get through right
away just be patient uh
you'll be able to get in
well
it sounds like that brings us up to
present date probably probably a good
place to stop uh we have to give echo
yes the opportunity yes you know i'm
sure there's some maybe some hawaiian
questions coming down
very sure very small but significant oh
sure wait so the place up in makawao
that was a chart house no no well it was
it was mine it was called makawa
steakhouse and i i owned it myself
makawao up country also known as up
country maui by the way yeah yeah um
also the was the name of your canoe club
hilani
hill any canoe club and then what did
you teach at punahou
uh
i taught fifth grade for the first two
years and then my last year i i went
from what from the fifth grade to uh the
academy and i taught ninth and tenth
grade english there did barack obama go
there did you teach barack obama well
you know i was i was going to say what
was interesting is uh
i
had i remained in fir teaching fifth
grade i would have he he came in that
next fifth grade class where i went up
to the academy
which uh
again god you know for him his sake he
probably he was saved yeah
he would end up a surfer somewhere yeah
yeah he
may have been a great water guy you know
who knows but yeah no he uh he dodged a
bullet
and then the chuck steakhouse and the
outrigger which outrigger is that i mean
back in because now outriggers
everywhere
yeah
they're a bunch yeah oh nowadays
yeah every corn show yeah okay so the at
the uh at the one right there and right
there at waikiki beach the main one
where dukes is now kind of right yeah
next huh yeah yeah place called dukes
now yeah it was up a couple of floors
above yeah yeah where dukes is okay
right and uh yeah next to the moana
hotel
yep that's where we stayed last time we
went no there you go boom
yeah
but chuck
guy he's a he'd be a great he's another
guy
chuck
chuck rolls a guy that started chuck
steakhouses
wonderful guy i'm hoping he's still
alive but i i don't know he's a geezer
we'll leave it at what he'll be still
alive we have to follow up with a butt
on that one we'll just call it hopefully
i'm sure he's still alive
sure enough awesome uh lance you got any
any closing thoughts you want to close
out with
just thank you very much for the
opportunity
appreciate it nice to meet you echo and
sir
and you you too but uh
yeah no i guess that's all i'm just
grateful and then
thank you
well right
right on like i said uh it i actually
heard about you through the this young
generation of the the kind i guess the
generation behind me i want to make
myself sound older make them sound young
they're all grown men yeah that are you
know
deep into the teams now but those were
the guys that kind of told me about what
you passed on to them so
uh it's awesome to have you on here and
and thanks for sharing some of those
lessons learned and um thanks for your
service
and and
thanks for the service and sacrifice of
of your brother as well
um you know we we owe everything to you
guys that that put in the work in the
early days and and created the the
tradition that we all try and uphold so
thanks for joining us and thanks for
everything you and your family have done
thank you
and with that
lance man has
left the building
a
pretty awesome guy to hang out with for
a couple hours yeah uh and by the way
just note
multiple times
multiple times he kind of referred to
himself as like decrepid and all this
stuff yeah this dude's 83 years old 82
years old almost 83 years old he is not
decrepit no and he is in
great shape and i'm sure maybe he's not
in as good shape as he was when he was
22 years old going through udt training
but
what an awesome guy and you know uh live
in it yeah
yeah you know how you can tell like even
young people
younger people whatever kind of just
when they walk up to you and you know
how they kind of talk and hold
themselves and walk from here to there
you can kind of tell you know you have a
small little gauge of oh
and yeah when he rolls up it's kind of
like [__] this guy is pretty
impressive for 82 just he's just rolling
up yeah well actually you just don't
even think he's 82. yeah
yes you think maybe he looks old for f
yeah oh this guy looks pretty old for a
51 year old yeah you know what i'm
saying yeah yeah that's kind of the
impression you get
uh
from the way he's carrying himself so
definitely a definitely a stud
and pretty cool um the fact that he's
had this influence on like this younger
generation i hate like again i'm
i i feel like i sound like i'm being
condescending when i call the
guys kind of
whatever behind me
not right behind me but you know like 10
years 15 years behind me in the teams
that's sort of the next generation i
don't know if that means next generation
but
this guy was a real mentor and
inspiration to a bunch of those guys so
uh that's kind of how i heard about him
and
pretty cool to have him on here and and
talk through some of this stuff
and definitely a
you know there's a couple things i heard
about him one thing i heard about and we
didn't bring this up again you know i
looked back and was like
apparently he just never wears a wetsuit
when surfing and stuff which is
you know this dude is you know we're all
like cold cold immersion you know i have
an ice bath you know
he's just going surfing for two hours
with no wetsuit
which by the way is cold in southern
california it's cold it's not warm
hawaii's is warm it's warm you don't
really need a wetsuit did you ever wear
a wetsuit when you were sponging in
hawaii no no no so you don't really need
a wetsuit
in hawaii correction you don't need a
wetsuit you don't okay you don't need a
website in hawaii especially when you
compare to here oh you're in the coldest
of in hawaii it's kind of like okay i'll
get out after three hours
usually it's like eight nine hours you
can be in the water yeah
that is so luxury isn't it hawaii's kind
of a little bit of paradise isn't it in
a way it is can you imagine he moved
from baltimore to hawaii yeah very
different that's a
game
changer
so
uh awesome awesome to have him in on
here as you know uh obviously it was
difficult for him to talk about his
brother even after all these years uh
you know his brother kind of followed
his footsteps and and
ended up being killed in vietnam and
you know i read a little bit about that
he he um
they were they were
basically
in a in a gun fight on an on a
ship or on a small boat
and um they took some either mortars or
rocket fire
and ended up
killing two seals um
lieutenant jg
dan mann who we talked about but also a
another seal named last name of boston
and then another one named neil who died
of wounds later
and you know that's another thing that
you know you get to hear this incredible
life and these adventures that lance man
has been on
and
you you you know we know i know he knows
that his brother didn't get those
opportunities
and
that's
something that uh we all need to think
about you know the all the guys that
didn't come home and
the fact that we get this opportunity to
go
and surf without a wetsuit and go and
become a lifeguard at 55 years old and
go and open up restaurants and move
around the world and like all those
things are opportunities that we have
because of
people that
made the sacrifice for us so
definitely something to think about um
with that
thanks for listening to the podcast uh
thanks for supporting you know we we did
feed lance manson he had he had some go
yeah he seemed fired up to buy it too
he was a little surprised when he tasted
it was like oh this is good yeah so if
you notice he didn't touch his water no
he went he chose the goal he won't all
go all the time
yeah he that's
you ever
i'm sitting here listening to the whole
deal and then you know how i don't know
it's like this weird map maybe i'm alone
on this maybe i'm not but it's this
weird map where it's like you kind of
think oh yeah when you're like in high
school or whatever
it's like that's a certain period of
your life it's like you got your whole
life ahead of you then you get your 20s
okay and then your 30s you kind of hit
your groove 40s and then once you hit
like 50-ish you kind of are like okay
you're kind of kind of looks like really
the destiny is already known yeah
exactly and you're kind of into
retirement mode a little bit you take
your foot off the gas you know and then
60 is kind of like you're straight up
retired you're cruising
that's kind of the map you kind of have
maybe subconsciously and bro he's like
talking about like oh yeah let me be a
lifeguard and making it past the test
i'm like bro are you not realizing the
map that we're all thinking about you
and then you think about it oh wait he
just had a different kind of attitude
where he was like oh no we're still
doing we're still going right now like
it's not over like we're still going or
whatever then you kind of consider it oh
wait you can do that yeah
and if you do it's kind i mean this is
just kind of deduction really but
i'm thinking man if you have that
attitude it's kind of like you can live
like a whole nother life in a way
where he's like 82 bro let's face it bro
if i even lived to 82
but am i gonna be like what the hell you
know it feels like i'd be i've been done
for like 20 years already but him he's
just like mad that he's even smelling
the doneness even though he's not i know
what the coffee thing yeah well it's
you know you said uh you said it's not
over right you ever seen like the
the kid in the wrestling tournament or
the kid in the basketball game or
whatever and like they're kind of losing
yeah yeah but there's one kid that he's
not done yet it's not over yet right in
his mind it's not over i'm not done with
this we're not done with this game right
and sometimes that kid can turn spark
and come back and make things happen and
get the victory
yeah
it's pretty wild
and so that attitude if it's not you
know when my
daughter was wrestling
uh
when she was in
trying to make it through to state and
in order to make it through the state
you got to win first second or third
and
her first day she lost a match
she won a couple she won a few she won
quite a few matches but she lost a match
which means the next day she was going
to have to win every single match
which is hard to do this is this is now
high level this isn't playing around or
you're trying to get to state
championships in california which is a
big deal
and we're actually out in a place
in the imperial valley of california
called brawley
and brawley is a great
athletic school and they have because
it's out in the middle of the desert
these are tough hard-working kids their
athletic programs are super hardcore
because they have nothing else to do
they live in brawley right you know i
got i got a friend that's from brawley's
in the teams and
you know he's like you're in brawley bro
that's what you're going to do you're
just like that's what you're going to
fight you're going to wrestle you're
going to play football like that's what
you're going to do
so my daughter she knows that you know
that night she's thinking
she if she loses one match she's not
going to stay in her senior year right
uh
that night and she was underweight
so she wasn't even close to like the
high end of her weight bracket she
probably she could have cut weight a few
pounds and gone one way squats down but
she didn't do that
so anyways we like
she loses she doesn't even talk to me on
the way back to the hotel room she's
just
angry and and and not even not she
wasn't really angry she was kind of like
a little bit sad you know just wasn't
talking to me wasn't talking to anybody
we get back to her i said you want
somebody and she says yeah i said what
do you want she's like pizza hut
so we order a bunch of pizza hut
whatever
and
you know she's still underweight but she
goes out the next day
and like i saw a little look in her face
that was like it's not over
this isn't over
and
she won her first match
and you could see almost
like a
sort of vibe coming over and then she
won her next match since she won her
next match and then it wasn't her last
match of the day but
her toughest match of the day we're in
brawley and she's wrestling against a
girl from brawley
and he's gross scrap
respect to brawley
uh
and they had a brawl
then my daughter won and and but you
know it's that attitude and then she
ended up going to states but that
attitude
of it's not over yet yeah but it's not
over yeah and to have that attitude with
life
that's a little lesson learned for
everybody today yeah a little lesson
learned for everybody
it's not over but i felt it yeah i felt
like he was kind of going harder at 82
than i am right now i kind of had that
feeling you know
i'd say that's an accurate statement
awesome all right um if you
want to support the podcast you want to
support yourself you want to stay in
good shape
you want to get some some lance man
jocko fuel in your system go to
jackalfield.com get yourself uh some
energy drinks that are actually good for
you stay in good shape and in good
health
yes good good keep getting right in the
game good point keep you right in the
game across the board get yourself some
protein look we can't afford to go to
chart house every night
right no oh yeah maybe when you're an e5
team guy like how's the e4 team guy
going to chart house we go up there and
get that prime rib boy so what is chart
house it's a restaurant it's a nice
restaurant a restaurant it's not like a
club you don't even know it was no it's
a restaurant it's a straight-up
restaurant
and there was one in coronado that was
all it's a different restaurant now but
it was on it was it was like a boathouse
it was on the water it was like a dock
basically real nice
and it was one of those things too when
you're young
like a young person's like a 20 20 year
old kid isn't supposed to be going on
the charts because you don't have enough
money for it unless you're in the teams
and you're a young team guy then you're
like up there ordering that 22 prime rib
back in 91.
feeling like you're kind of a boss right
kind of a boss like hey i'm rolling in
the chart house you're like a business
person right there's people in there
with like shirts
like real like whatever
nice shirts and stuff you know so so
wait this is the chart house what's the
dynamic when you go in there is it like
a military no no no no no no it's just
more higher end
well it was created by team guys right
so it's kind of chill like the waiters
and waitresses would be wearing like
hawaiian shirts
but they're also charging you know like
twenty nine dollars for a piece of meat
right so it's well and that's back then
so like today would be the equivalent of
like probably
40 bucks
you know 50 bucks
per
per main course yeah yeah so yeah you're
right so like a
if you're if you don't have some some
money yeah or whatever that's going to
be not just casually rolling out there
unless you're a young
guy in the teams you have no expenses
other than just what you're going to eat
you could get after it
did you guys
uh like know that it was kind of like
has the team guy ready i knew i knew it
had team red roots but no one
i you know i always thought well maybe
someone's going to be like here you guys
are you know are you guys in the shield
teams no one ever said that to me you
know they just kind of which is pretty
obvious we're in this freaking seal
things are in corn we're like literally
500 meters from base
[Music]
but i think maybe
what's funny is
i thought that the chart house i thought
that i was at like the first chart house
in 1990 he's like no it started in 1964.
so i was way off base on that one oh
yeah yeah it was interesting too he and
he didn't go as deep into it his uh
kamayana experience in in hawaii but all
those places it's weird because
i kind of think where he all the places
he was talking about like i know those
places or whatever but this is back in
the day so it's like different you know
so it kind of has that contrast or
whatever when he was like outrigger you
know the outrigger but now bro
outriggers everywhere
but the main one that's the one he was
talking about yeah he's talking about
that main one that you stay at by dukes
yeah i've been to that one oh yeah it's
kind of a hype scenario that's the
height they got a they got a bar like on
the beach situation you know what i'm
saying that's where i proposed to my
current life by the way you know what we
had a weird
scenario with my my wife the way things
kind of finally got solidified but
when i finally got her a ring let's say
yeah we finally got her a ring
i asked her to come out for dinner we we
went out for dinner guess where we went
to dinner we went to the chart house not
not even the one in coronado
we went to the one that was down by the
pier or whatever in san diego so it was
sort of an extra level of hype
it wasn't just going to coronado yeah
i'm gonna take you extra level of hype
and i had that little so i told her to
get dressed up and whatever like you
know i put on like a shirt you know
because back in the day it was hard to
get a shirt on i understand like a
t-shirt was kind of hard but like
putting on a collared shirt was sort of
a big deal yeah yeah so she knew
something was off some formal yeah
uh
yep get yourself a jackal few
chocofuel.com get some get some of the
drinks from wawa
get some any of it from the vitamin shop
that's going to help you out
uh get yourself some clothes get
yourself some american-made clothes
straight up
is there like a new factory gene or
something or am i just seeing like a
factory gene is the same gene we've
always had that's called the factory two
types of genes factory gene
delta 68. delta 68 is lighter
a little thinner
factory heavy so if you're in michigan
or you're in
uh maine
and it's going to be winter time get
yourself a set of factory jeans if
you're in socal
or you're deploying to vietnam
get yourself a pair of delta 68s
and all of it is made in america all of
it's made in america and look
that's the way everything should be made
if you're an american you should be
buying something that's made in america
why would you not do that i'll tell you
why because you think well you know i
want to save 14
but when you save that 14
you're actually costing
yourself infinitely more on the back
side when your country is crumbling and
when you feel in your soul that you're
enslaving human beings overseas at the
very least keeping them at the very
least keeping people enslaved
overseas don't let that happen go to
origin usa.com get yourself some boots
get yourself a ghee get
no one even thought that guys were going
to be comfortable no that wasn't it was
sort of you just had to accept that
these were uncomfortable yes
let's face it you're going to put a gi
on you're not happy i felt that way
you're not happy putting on a geek until
now now you're putting you kind of smile
a little bit
yeah right you are crazy you kind of
smile a little bit when you put on an
origin key you kind of feel like yeah oh
that felt yeah a little smile yeah you
didn't think it was possible
you didn't think it was possible it's
more than possible it's a reality it's
happening originusa.com
check some of that out also other
clothing
jocko clothing go to jackostore.com
where you can represent discipline
equals freedom it's a big deal
discipline equals freedom
that goes deep i know you didn't know
that when you made it up or whatever but
but it goes deep
oh you know uh shirt locker even leif
babin you know
just did not support the everyone must
get stoned t-shirt yeah so that one that
one is very controversial but it's not
for everybody i did not know that there
was gonna i
to me this is this is this is why i know
this is why i don't trust myself this is
why i always question myself the so i
always think oh you know i might not
have the best idea so for those of you
who don't know we made a t-shirt it's
based on it's for the shirt lockers
certain officers a subscription thing
and you get a t-shirt every month and
they're we we can be a little bit more
let's say uh uh creative with the
designs we can take a little bit more
risk we can get a little bit wild so
this is an idea i had forever i thought
this was like the best selling teacher
of all time this is gonna everyone's
gonna want this one like we have to back
order it like a bunch of crazy stuff is
gonna happen we're gonna see him on on
uh you know the cover of uh fashion
magazines throughout the world
so there's a story about vietnam guy has
a stoner rife we used a weapon called
the stoner the stoner 63 in vietnam
seals used it we were famous for using
it
and well a guy i knew got went and
picked up his weapon from the armory and
someone else that had taken the weapon
to vietnam on an alternate tour
had carved into the butt stock everybody
must get stoned and i thought that oh
that's so cool you know it's the 60s
that's a song by bob dylan i think
everybody must get snowed
so i thought hey dude of course we'll
make a t-shirt
and people just didn't get it man and
it's not even just some people don't
like it because there's a machine gun on
it some people don't like it because it
says get stoned on it you put those two
things together the only people that are
gonna like it is like me and like one
other person i guess yeah yeah me i like
it yeah so anyways you're gonna roll the
dice a little bit i guess
apparently
we never ran into that but hey man
that's the only one that's kind of
gotten the neg the negative feedback
no no no there's always going to be your
odd guy like you know or person whatever
who's like
not liking something so hey man i dig it
it's not for everybody we knew that
going in yeah you know but uh yeah
sometimes i guess apparently sometimes
these shirts go hard you know yeah
so if you're feeling edgy
if you want to support kind of just look
like
like give the support
and you also want to take risks because
you're a risk taker you're kind of
person that says you know what i'm in
the game
you know what you know what you're
saying yourself it's not over i'm not
done wearing cool t-shirts i'm not it's
not over yet you can you can check out
the shirt locker yep
and that is on jocko's tour yeah dot com
uh subscribe to the podcast don't forget
about jocko underground we're putting
we're putting a word out on jocko
underground answering questions on that
jockowunderground.com if you want to
check that out we got a youtube channel
putting videos up
you can see
what lance man looks like can see what
82 should look like if you're squared
away if you're pteen every day
uh so check that out psychological
warfare we got flipsidecanvas.com dakota
meyer got a bunch of books hey i read i
kind of re-read a section from by water
beneath the walls
i i guess that might be bad planning or
whatever but that section about the udts
and the psychological i just had to kind
of go with it again
but that book is ben milligan uh by
water beneath the walls freaking great
book you know i've written a bunch of
books too
including a novel called final spin
just check those out leadership books
and whatnot
kids books
if you haven't gotten all the kids you
know all the kids books that i've
written
you're not a good person
you're not you're not you're not a good
person right
you're not you don't care about them
yeah it's hard to connect those dots you
know good person no books i i understand
fully wait you saying it's hard to
connect those thoughts yeah like if you
if you consider yourself a good person
meanwhile you didn't do the book thing
right it's hard yeah you're you're hard
you're a hard time convincing me that
you're a good person when you're like oh
yeah well i know a bunch of kids but i
didn't get any of this life-changing
book that's going to help them in every
way and everything that they do in their
life no
when you look in the mirror you should
recognize you're a bad person
so don't do it get all these kids just
get them
hand them out
hand them out i can't handle these books
out myself what am i going to do like
walk around america handing out books no
you got to do it get in the game
buy them and give them to all these kids
help out all those kids
there you go ashlandfront.com if you
need help with leadership inside your
organization don't forget about extreme
ownership.com where we got online
training
and
if you want to help
service members active and retire
active and retired service members you
want to help their families out you want
to help out gold star families check out
mark lee's mom she's got a a charity
organization it's at america's
mightywarriors.org
also check out
heroesandhorses.com where micah finn's
got cool stuff going on
letting people get back to themselves
uh as far as the
the social media thing
where the algorithm is hunting you
look
just because there's bad things out
there in the world don't mean you need
to like shy away from it but you got to
be on your toes when you go in there all
right so you go in there and check out
echocharls.com you check out
jockowink.com
be on your toes watch out for the
algorithm it'll get you
and uh thanks once again
thanks once again to lance mann for
coming on and
[Music]
and thanks to dan mann his brother who
who died on april 7 1967
in service to our great nation
we are grateful for your sacrifice and
we will not forget
and on top of that thanks to all the
udt frogmen of the past who laid down
the foundation of the organization
that
this generation
has done our best to uphold
and to the rest of the members
past and present of the army navy air
force and marines who also
continue to hold up the warrior
traditions of our great nation thank you
for your service and thanks also
for the work done by our police law
enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service all the first responders
out there thanks for your service here
on the home front
to keep us safe
and to everybo everyone else out there
let's keep it in mind
that it's not over
it's not over
you got one shot you got one go at this
gig
and i recommend that you
be like lance man
and
live it
go out there and live it
and until next time this is echo and
jocko
out